Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday morning podcast.
and ahhh
just checking in on you.
How are you? How's your week going? Ah, back to the grind. Huh?
Back to the fucking grind. You two. Oh yeah. How was your,
how was your Ra
time off? Do you have a nice holiday? Did Ya? Did Ya did? Yeah.
Oh yeah. How old is she now? Really? Really?
Can I jerk off DOR yet? Just kidding. I'll see it. Break. Alright. Oh,
you haven't those fucking conversations. Oh,
the holidays are over and it's back to the grind. Sit in traffic.
Go into your cubicle. I think I'm going to kill my boss
if I don't drive into the wall. Um,
and I actually had a fucking panic attack. Not as semi panic attack.
Sorta like I fucking nose dives into a bit of a depression. Yes.
They just stick another fucking year. Here we go. Here we go again.
Here we fucking go again. Uh, we have a,
a mechanical problem with the aircraft.
We're just going to pull over here or the, uh, tarmac.
We have a landing light that is uh, in operable at this moment.
We're going to sit tight here and wait till a, the mechanics come out here,
which I do not have a estimated time on at this point, but a well,
we will get some better information. We'll act,
get back to you as soon as he can add dad till then.
Now it's getting me apologize for the delay at a, uh,
just trying to sit back and like, especially kid a,
I've got to try to keep the air on.
I apologize if it gets a little hot back there now the fucking year or that
another fucking year of that. The shows are great.
It's the getting the, getting to the shows. Um,
oh God. People taking their fucking shoes. I look,
if you take your shoes off and you have socks on, I fucking get it. All right.
Just don't rub your feet together. I've talked about it.
Perform [inaudible] can you not rub your fucking feet together? Foot, foot,
foot, foot, foot, foot. It fucking drives me nuts. That just,
I just want to punch the back of the fucking chair. Um, anyways,
uh, what is going on with me? I'm going to be on the cow calling
cow herd show, uh, today. Hyping a F is for family.
I'm going into Netflix today and we're going to do our little song and dance and
pitch them our season arc for a season two.
Basically. Uh, that's what you do after you do the first one. And they go,
hey Yo, we're pretty good. Pretty good, but now where are you going to go?
Where are you going?
Go with it now and then you've got to get on the IEE yet. Dah, Dah, Dah.
I want to do the doodle. He does this. She does that.
Give it some more fucking money please.
And they go, we'll think about it then. Yeah. Everybody walks out going,
I think they look, you think we're good? I think we're good. I don't know here.
When should we? Here? Tuesday, Wednesday at the latest.
We wanna thank everybody for a rat flat, a friend of Sky's here today.
Fortunately,
we're adding a little bit of weather in the Dallas Fort Worth area.
Who number 72 in line. Um,
unfortunately is really nothing we can do here. Be patient,
we try and make up some title in the air. You'll trust Loulou faster. Um,
part a little more fuel. We can try and put her own hole in the ozone layer,
you know, another year of that. But you know what else?
You know sometimes, you know, I don't know.
Every once in a while I just fucking drive down the street.
I just see a homeless guy laying on the sidewalk sleeping, you know?
And as much as uncomfortable as it, you just looking, just like, you know,
I would fucking love to do that right now.
Just pull over and lay down on the ground and take a fucking nap.
Now I don't want to live outside.
Yeah.
And granted,
I know that that homeless guy is sleeping during the day because at night that's
when the people come up out of the sewer drains,
like in fucking a escape from New York, you know,
cause they have to feed. So when you're homeless, you gotta be up at night.
You know,
a lot of people is Bob taking a nap in the middle of the fucking afternoon.
That's because at night, right, he's having like a fucking,
you know, a two by four fight fighting off.
Right. He's dealing with that shit. So, uh,
but I liked the nap part of it. I'm actually looking at the homeless guy's life,
the way a woman looks at a man's life. Like, that looks fine. I want to do that.
I don't want to pay the price for it, but I'd like that in my life.
Equal rights. Oh,
I am in a fucking mu. I'm
alright. I go on Facebook because I'm an old white guy. I love,
I love the Facebook. I absolutely love it. I didn't give a fuck.
Even if I delete my account,
they never deleted because of that creepy [inaudible] who I judged by the actor
who played him. I don't even know what the real Zuckerberg looks like.
Said his name. Oh, I fucked up the other day.
I said Lamar London instead of Lamar Hunt. He was the original owner of the,
of the, uh, Dallas, Texas. Lamar Lundy was part of the fearsome foursome.
And what's funny is that's the fucking name I can never remember.
You know when they go name the first and force them, I'm always like,
Oh I Rosie Greer, Merlin Olsen.
Aww. Deacon Jones.
Okay.
And
yeah,
Lamar Lundy's like the bass player in a huge band. Right.
You can never the bass player, you know, unless they're really, if they're,
unless they're like one of those front man bass players like Steve Harris,
you know, Billy sheen and you know,
back in the day John and to whistle, you know,
or they play in a trio cause then you only have to remember three names.
But if they play in a band of four or more people,
you just can never remember the bass player's name. You know Lamar Lundy.
Is that alright? What's,
what's the front floor for the Steelers? I don't think I could name that was me.
Joe Green LC. Greenwood. Dwight White,
Eh, uh,
yeah.
And the Bass player. What the fuck was his name? It's a great name too. Oh,
it's a fucking shame. I'm, I'm going to have to look that up.
I have to look that up. Like you can't disrespect the fucking 70 Steelers.
They went forward. Oh, and titles. You can't, you can't disrespect the team,
you know, clues. Fan Base. I'm not going to get into an area where we goes,
okay.
Steeler's front for, there's a bunch of people in fucking, uh,
is a bunch of people in Pittsburgh right now screaming at their fucking
the steel curtain. Who were they?
Okay.
The steel curtain, Yada, Yada, Yada, Yada, Yada. Me,
Joe Green, LCR already fucking homes. What a great name.
Ernie Holmes. It just got me down in I, Ernie Holmes. You know,
he's going to be at least six, five. Um, anyways,
they don't have any man's names left anymore, do they?
This is coming from a guy named bill. Won't you come Home Bill Bailey?
Okay,
let's go back here. What did I want? Oh, here's what I wanted to talk about.
The, uh, the Los Angeles Rams.
It's a St Louis Rams slash Los Angeles rams slash
Cleveland Ramps. Hi. Slash Cleveland Rams.
They're coming back.
I'm so psyched that they're coming back.
I'm so psyched that it was the rams and not the chargers or the Raiders there.
Aes. I'm so fucking excited. Okay.
La does not need the chargers or hey,
we don't need a stay away. Okay.
La needs the rams.
Okay.
Blue and yellow. The Rams, the Los Angeles Rams.
That's what they need. They don't need, they don't need the fucking,
they don't need to bring the Raiders. But if you bring the Raiders back,
the city of Los Angeles, if you bring the Raiders back,
you're basically signing off on the fact that someone's going to get stabbed or
shot. It's just, it's a fact.
Just watch the 30 for 30 on the fucking Los Angeles Rams, the one that ice cube,
uh, narrates the way he's talking and all that shit. It's fucking,
it's actually inadvertently like hilarious.
It's just the level of like,
okay,
La doesn't need you, don't, you don't fucking need it. Somebody's to like,
they can't handle, they can't handle those colors.
They can't handle the pirate on the side of the,
keep it in fucking Oakland where people just dress up like it's going to be a
musical. And even then somebody got shot at a fucking 49ers. Raiders,
like a pregame thing. You don't need it. You know, it's funny,
everybody always talks about the Philly fans and how east coast fans. Oh,
Yankees, red sox. It's nothing compared to out here. People die out here.
Guy went to a fucking Dodgers game with this kid and head on a giants Jersey and
he had, he has brain damage for the rest of his fucking life.
Cause this fucking two,
two guys jumped up while his kids sat there and watched.
That was in a fucking baseball game. The rams.
That's it. Hi. Where are the rams? Perfect.
Okay.
You don't need the autumn wind was a raid.
You don't need to bring that to the inland empire.
[inaudible] you don't need to do that. I'm telling you.
And I'm charge charger fans on the one fucking charger game that I fucking went
to add. Um, I'll, you know,
me law had almost got into a fight when we were there and I was rooting for the
chargers. I just had a patriots hat on. It was an old school patriots had,
it was all fucking beat up.
They will play in the fucking colts on cheer in the chargers. That alone,
I mean I expected to get a little bit of shit right, a little bit of Shit,
but to get to the point that it's going to be a physical confrontation and
somebody dumps a beer on you and that type of shit. All my bad,
but they did it on purpose like yeah, fuck that.
Keep those fucking animals where they're at. Keep them where they're at.
Like just, you know, keep the rocky horror picture show in the end zone.
Keep that up and fucking Oakland plus it's the Oakland Raiders. That's their,
fuck it. I'm kind of giving it inadvertently given Oakland Shit.
I don't mean to do that. It's the Oakland Raiders. All right.
Okay.
They came down here before they tried to make it in Hollywood. They couldn't,
you know, they got a couple of guest stars on the fall guy, you know.
Then they did an episode of full House and then it just sort of dried up for,
and then they, they put their tail between their legs. They went back home,
they took over their dad's business. I don't understand why they coming back.
Yeah,
and why everybody all at once. All of a sudden everybody wants to come here.
We've been sitting here for 20 fucking years without a team.
Now all of a sudden everybody wants to come back.
The Ram should come back there. Los Angeles is team. All right.
Now I know the charges started here in la, la,
like their first or first year or two on the AFL. But uh,
yeah, keep it down to San Diego. You know, it's Shitty.
You don't want to stand by. Standing with Santa Ana is a great place.
It's one of them met most mellow, great places. When you go down there,
you're like, this is everything that La should be. It's chill,
it's fucking relaxed. You've got the weather. This is great.
It's not the grind of La.
That's what San Diego feels like when I go down there and fucking love it.
But then for whatever fucking reason,
you go to a sporting event and these people turn into fucking maniacs,
not [inaudible] games just to charge your games. They just did fucking animals.
Um, I don't know.
Maybe if they built them a nicer stadium and then they gave them a mascot.
I have no idea. But I do think it's really fucked up that, you know,
the Raiders are going to leave, you know,
and the charges are going to leave and St Louis is leaving basically because
they don't like their stadiums and the throwing a fucking temper tantrum. It's,
the NFL is so fucked up man. But sports in general that they do that to people.
It's like, dude, it's your league. It's your fucking business.
You know what I mean? You don't like your fucking place of work, but you know,
build another one. I don't know.
There's, but there's no way to organize people to get them just to,
to stand up to owners. Right.
Like I remember hearing when I was working in Indianapolis in Indianapolis,
you know, they played at the, I was at the Hoosier dome or whatever. Um,
when they were building that Lucas oil field,
this taxi driver when I was there was telling me that, that the city will,
they weren't even done paying off the RCA dom or whatever the fuck they called
it. They weren't even done paying that off.
And then they had this fucking thing. If you've never been to Indianapolis,
I don't know if, uh, the are the Hoosier dough MRCA Dome,
whatever the fuck it was called, if that's still standing.
But when they've were fucking building Lucas oil field and it was right next to
the, uh, the old one, which I believe is torn down,
you could fit like two of those inside the new one and stack two on top of each
other. Um,
the size of this fucking new one island can only imagine how much tax payers
have to pay for that shit. It's fucking stupid.
The whole thing's fucking stupid. I,
I really believe that once you make a stadium that should be a stadium and you
just keep fixing the fucking thing up the way.
I'm fixing up my shed hall of a house. Sorry,
I just discovered something else that was fucked up with my house.
But you know what? All right, now I'm the stubborn German Irish guy in me.
I'm just like, you know what? Bring it up.
Sink every fucking dime I have into this goddamn
taken on water. Shit hole of a boat. I'm done. I'm fucking done. Like,
uh, I'm having somebody come over today to look at my garage. And uh,
somebody built off of, uh, my office here,
they built this closet and they extended this room itself.
And I don't know who's friend of a friend built this fucking thing,
but it literally sits, uh,
right above my garage and on these two wooden, like,
I don't even know what the terminology is. They're not two by fours.
Was it four by six is whatever.
It's wood that's always bothered me. And then down,
I talked about this in the last podcast,
but beneath that is my garage.
And in my garage right underneath that wood is a steel beam that goes across the
garage.
There's a steel beam going down one side and not on the other cause there's a
window there. So they said, well,
forget supporting the entire fucking structure.
Let's put a window here so I can look at my neighbor's house that's fucking six
inches away. Yeah. One of the first things I did when I bought the houses,
I put a shade up and pulled it down and I've never brought it back up again
until the other day when the guy looked. Um, so anyways,
I think when you get like a stadium, like just, just fix the fucking thing up.
Just fix it up and keep fixing the fucking thing up
and that's it. What do you do? Have you ever,
ever gotten tickets into a luxury box? It sucks. It sucks.
The food socks. You're 9 million miles away from the game.
You now the upper deck is further away from the game. It fucking blows.
I wish you guys, you young people out there,
I wish back in the day you could have gone to like, uh, like
the Boston Garden Mei belief garden. Um, I mean, I never went to a game there.
I took a tour of the place, but I, I'll just go with the ones that I went to,
the old fucking Boston Garden, dude, you are on top of the fucking game.
It was like Thunderdome when you were,
you were in the upper deck of those fucking stadiums. Dude.
You literally felt like if you lean too far forward,
you're going to fall down and you would hit the ice. That's how steep it was.
But now they're like the fire code and you know,
to get the fucking elephants out, you know, it's got to be fucking more chill,
you know, a relax grade. I don't know, I'm not into it,
but I'm psyched that the rams are back. I feel like the ram should be there.
I feel like San Diego should be in San Diego.
I feel like Oakland should be in Oakland, you know,
like the way it was when I was a kid. Um, and that's it.
And I know I was kind of fucking rough on fucking la fans, but it's true.
And I'm, I went down to Anaheim one time, we would share it on the red sox. We,
and on our red sox shit, you know, but we weren't conscious about it.
I used to wear red shocks,
suck stuff into a Yankee Stadium and people would break my balls,
chance some shit and point at me when I laughed it off and they saw that I was a
good shit or whatever. Then they, then they would say,
well how long are you down here in New York? I live down here. I really,
but blah blah blah blah, you know,
and then they'd score and they'd fucking laugh at me and give me shit or
whatever and you know, and if we score one won the game,
I wouldn't fucking point at him and stuff. I wasn't a, I wasn't a dick.
All right. Cause this is my thing. If you go to a stadium with the other jersey,
you got to expect to get some shit. All right.
But like once you demonstrate that you're not going to be a fucking obnoxious
ass, people should leave you alone. You know what I mean?
You're just making a road trip.
You show in the other stadium respect that you wanted to come. And see it.
And that should be the fucking end of it.
And that was my experience when I was living in New York.
I came out here and it's just like, no,
I'm going to stab you in the fucking neck. So,
well actually, you know, I'm always bitching about the population problems.
You know what? Fuck all that. Fuck the last 18 minutes of this podcast,
bring their aid. It's bring them down here.
Maybe some people will fucking die and it'll be a couple less people
procreating, you know, build it. You really have to take it to there. Yeah,
I think I did. Um, all right.
You know what they kind of reminds me of though is the, uh,
these fucking people who are baiting Trump supporters. Now, I'm not,
I'm not going to, you know, get into politics here, but you know,
you gotta call a spade a spade here. I mean, the,
those people are mouth breathing morons. Uh,
and Trump is up there not saying anything and getting them to go absolutely
fucking nuts. Uh, and it's actually,
uh,
it's like watching a movie where they're kind of warning you about,
I dunno how when I watched Trump and I listened to what he says it,
it reminds me of like, I, there's some couple of Hollywood movies that I've seen
and the person running for office is just so over the top and ridiculous.
It just reminds you that you watching a movie, you just like,
why did they go that far? If they just fucking dialed it back a little bit, I,
this could be a little more believable and, uh, you'd have a much better,
much better movie. And then along came Trump and, uh, you know,
I owe all of those, uh, movies and apology,
but I do have to say this, the fucking nerds who went to the,
one of the latest Trump rallies and had a sign,
Obama is a good president. This country already is great, but they,
you just went in there, you know,
you went in there to pick a fight and then they videotaped it.
And when they tore up your signs, which you knew they were going to do,
you get to be like, Trump's support is his hit a new low.
I guess the reason why they're doing that right now,
which is really what that is, is basically entrapment.
That's like they throw drugs at your feet. Oh, what's that? Um, no,
that's actually not so well, what if like some smoking hot chick,
he just walk up to some fatty and she's just like, Hey,
you want me to fuck your Dick? Give me 20 bucks. And he's like, okay,
let me finish this muffin. And the cops just come in. You can't fucking do that.
You can't temp. You can't tempt somebody like that.
And I feel like that's kind of what they did with them. But, um,
having said all that, yeah. Um, that Trump thinks stopped being funny,
like a good four to six months ago and she just like, wait a minute,
it's just going, going to get the nomination. You know,
all I'm begging for is just give me two reasonable human beings,
two sane, reasonable human beings.
You know what I mean? That, that, you know,
on either fucking side and then give me that third fucking option.
Just be fucking reasonable. Don't walk around.
I'm going to bomb the shit out of. So it's the fuck is wrong with you.
[inaudible]
it's always the guys who don't have to go over there and do, Oh,
do you know I'm fuck, I'm the tough guy behind the fucking desk. Um,
I can't believe nobody slept at wig off yet, you know? Um, all right, let's, uh,
let's plow ahead.
As somebody who's trying to keep up with both hockey and basketball,
this is what ends up happening.
You just end up watching your own teams and you don't know what the rest of the
League is doing.
And that's what's going on with me because I used to check in with the Dallas
Stars and uh, in the, uh, the Black Hawks and the, um,
yeah.
And the La Kings are just teams I really like watching and I haven't had a
chance to, so I just been watching the Bruins fucking lose, lose,
lose on this road trip. We lost a jersey.
Then we lost to a fuck. Did we lose? No,
we beat Jersey, right? We beat Jersey and we've lost three in a row.
We lost two. The fliers, the rangers and Ottawa.
I will say auto was the,
was the most enjoyable loss because it's my belief that the best thing in sports
right now is three on three overtime hockey.
Even if you fucking everybody who bitches about hockey, this is the hockey.
You want to see no fights racing up and down the ice in someone's can basically
going to score within five fucking minutes. You'll love it. Um,
I don't know if there's any youtube videos you could watch the whole fucking
overtime. They, the Ottawa Bruins over time it was, it was, it was,
we lost and I was, I almost stood up and applauded.
It was that fucking enjoyable to see. Um,
was incredible. It's almost like when you watch it, you're like, you know what?
Maybe there's too many people playing professional hockey.
I want to take anybody's job.
But if it was three on three from the get go of Jesus Christ,
the whole fucking game, you know, what happened? Somebody would die.
The cardio would just be off the fucking,
has anybody interviewed a NHL player yet to say like, what is it like,
what's it like to, to, to, um,
to take a shift or like three on three overtime versus when it's a five on five,
not including the goaltenders. Okay. For all you fucking number nerds out there.
Like what is that like? Are you more winded? Is there an unbelievable freedom?
Because you don't have to worry about getting checked.
It's going to be fucking incredible feeling like you're playing pond hockey.
Um, anyways. And then the fucking Celtics, they finally won last night.
Of course I missed the Goddamn game.
I just saw them to fucking lost to the Knicks do that Porzingis guy.
Holy Fuck. He's like a 10 foot Larry Bird.
He was looking like that in the first quarter. This guy was just hitting one,
three after another and then he took one shot, three point shot.
This guy's like seven foot two or three or something.
He took a 3.0 from like fun.
It looked like he was like eight feet behind the arc and it just won't wash.
And what's funny is it's each three that he hit the fucking noises that the
crowd was making. Like basically this is the guy, I think this is the guy.
Like he'd hit one, they like, they cheer,
but you hear like underneath the chair here. Oh, then he hits a second.
Then the third one I like freaking the fuck out
and you can tell, uh, mellow loves fucking play with them. They're past,
knew each other. It was fucking great.
So I'm sitting there watching it going like, all right,
if we're going to lose these guys, at least I get to watch, you know,
the oldest star having fun with the new kid. Um,
you know, it was, it was just really fun to watch the two of them playing.
And uh, Jesus Christ, God help the League if they get a fucking point Garda,
well not the whole league, but I mean they could fuck with the Cavaliers,
couldn't they? Maybe. I don't know shit about hoop. I'm going to shut up.
But I enjoyed watching them play and everything's going great. And I guy,
so you know what, I'm going to watch the rest of this fucking game.
And who knows? Maybe I'll watch one of these guys put up 40. Right? Who knows?
And uh, and then I'll send it all went to shit.
Maloz backing up the fucking court. The refs standing there,
he steps on the refs 40 turns his fucking ankle and then that's it.
It's fucking it. He tried coming back out after the half and then he just said,
fuck it left. I'm out.
I dropped my fucking 20 for the evening. I'll see. And he fucking leaves.
I saw the other night,
he's still not fucking playing cause he stepped on the ref's foot so he fucking
leaves. So I'm like, all right, let's see if the kid can lead the team here.
And then next thing you know,
he's got like five fucking files and he sitting down,
and this is funny, this funny thing is we still lost the Goddamn game.
I actually love the Celtics. They young and everything, but they uh,
they love scoring like 35 in the first quarter, you know,
and going up by 10, 12, 19.
I watched him lose the Memphis to having a 19 point fucking lead and uh,
I don't know,
I still like them and if think it just fucking hang onto what God damn lead.
I could enjoy it a little bit more. But by the way,
it's the last night they were playing the paces and um,
one of the fuck most fucked up things ever.
I was sitting there looking at the pacers wearing these uniforms and like where
do I know those uniforms from? And I looked it up online.
They were wearing the uniforms, the same uniforms that they wear in that movie.
Hoosiers, right. My correct in assuming that,
let me look this up before I make fun of them for actually doing that Hoosiers
movie.
Okay.
Images. It's all going to be gene Hackman's face, right? Yeah.
They were wearing those things. Do you realize how fucked up that is?
Okay.
Hey black guys, why don't you put on these uniforms?
That white pill we used to wear when you weren't allowed to play?
Yeah,
I thought I wanted to say lines of way. Those are fucking what? It was.
Fucking a white whitey verse. Whitey. The all white days, right?
Look at the pictures.
A picture of the fucking team in black and white that they were doing.
All right. Number 43 white number 15 white number 53 white,
25 white, 13 white, 12 white, 14 white. The other guy can't read his number.
They're all white. Why would a, why would you have them wear those?
When did one of you going to have the uh, the color barrier?
Broken uniforms one day this year? I don't know.
It seemed like an odd fucking choice to me. However,
Indiana has such a weird fucking such a weird fucking state, you know,
it's really just like a, you know, just odd.
Golly Gee. Aww shucks white people slash
okay.
Astoundingly racist. You know, like as much shit as Boston.
Like the only places that gets shit for being racist. Basically.
It's the south and Boston, Massachusetts. And now having been on the road,
I dunno about how fucking long she kept this weekend. A
okay.
We, yeah, no, there's no new versus when the, uh, when you're still at the gate,
they're just like
touching everybody on American Airlines flight one, nine or seven,
six to Albuquerque. Um,
we're still waiting for our flight crew to show up.
So it's probably going to be another 40 minutes if you'd like to get something
to eat, but don't want it too far.
That shit.
I don't even know why I just went into that. Um, I don't even fucking remember.
You know what I've been,
I've been doing this long enough to just say fuck that idea and I'm just going
to continue on. All right.
So we got a patriots verse the chiefs this weekend in playoffs,
football playoffs. Um, and I think that, uh,
we could possibly win that game by the skin of our teeth.
It all depends on who comes back. Uh,
but if we do not have an offensive line, then uh, our,
our goose is cooked because our starting running back,
I can't even remember his fucking name. He's been out for so long. I, I,
you know, I really need to just pick a sport. You can't fucking watch 'em off.
That's what I'm trying to do. I'm watching the Patriots,
Bruins and Celtics and I don't even know anybody's fucking name.
Any mice know the fucking lines or the Bruins. I don't even know.
I'm just sitting there.
Okay.
You know what it is it, this is my fucking, I don't know what the,
that the psychological term is like, oh, I'm going to, I'm going to get them.
I'm going to watch the Bruins much all the Bruins game,
so much all the Bros Games and then Thursday comes out.
I'll get the basketball coach, I'll start it.
And I'm just fucking sitting here binge watching this shit like a maniac.
I think I need to step back for a second and get my priorities in order and
realize that the Patriots are in the fucking playoffs and the Bruins and Celtics
is still in the regular season. I are just be paying attention to the Patriots.
Right.
Um,
I dunno. I think, uh, I think c, I think it's Seattle. I think Seattle,
they had their fucking little, you know,
when you went again the way Seattle won last week,
which is basically the other team basically screws the poach.
You got to start to feel like you kind of a team of destiny. Right?
And I know one year the Patriots, you know,
the ravens missed a field goal and that got us into a Superbowl. But uh,
that one made me feel like we backed in. But like, I really think like Seattle,
if it wasn't fucking nine degrees out or 10 below zero,
I thought that was really in the vikings favor kind of slowed them down a little
bit, even out the field. And I can say that knowing nothing about the vikings,
I'm going to shut the fuck up right now. How about that?
Would that be all right? Um, anyways,
well that's the half hour here. I got to, uh, I gotta go fucking, uh,
put on my monkey suit here and makes sure that I look like I'm from Indiana when
I go in to go pitch the second season here. So anyways,
thank you everybody for listening to the a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning podcast. Just checking in on you, uh,
episode. Uh, now we're going to do a little throwback shit. Um,
I didn't see any advertising for this week. Um,
maybe you listen to some advertising right now that are recorded on my phone on
the way to the fucking meeting.
I have no fucking idea what you're going to hear right now,
but I know eventually you're going to hear some throwback shit from a podcast
from a year gone by. All right. Have a great weekend. Your cuts.
Yeah. Shit. I gotta read five of these fucking things. The advertisements here,
this is not the throwback part. This is the advertising part.
I guess I missed two of them on Monday. So here we go.
Am v M t watches everybody movement watches was started by two college dropouts.
We're flunkies man with the idea to make quality watches that don't break the
bank. Starting at 95 bucks and sold online.
They cut out all the bullshit retail markup,
supposedly movement. Sent some watches over here.
Question Mark. I guess that wasn't supposed to read that. Yeah, they did.
They right. They, I got them. They're great. I'm not lying. I have in my closet.
I'm not wearing them, you know, but I liked him.
Quality material and sleek design. The perfect everyday watch. It's easy.
Order online today for free shipping. Free returns in a 24 month warranty.
Join the movement and say no big hand retail markups and saying to great style.
Checkout MVMT
watches.com/burr and you'll get 50 15% off your entire purchase.
That's M v M t, watches.com/berk.
What's up Cleo? All right. Oh Shit. Let me go a little. Boom.
[inaudible] me on the, he's having a nice fucking dry tank,
but who do to me and ease me, Andy, please.
No more reason to paint your fucking balls. Cousin. I said dry.
You catching some flies with your fucking Dick? I don't know.
I'm out of ideas with that son. What's she,
what's the secret to New Year's resolutions to make the first step real easy.
Like the first thing you do every day.
Put on underwear this year out with the old and with the new step into a new
fresh pair of me undies, the world's most comfortable underwear.
And it's the easiest resolution you can make. Head to me,
undies.com to choose from a variety of styles and limited edition patterns for
both men and women. And they'll be delivered right to your door, man. Me.
And he says, the next level of underwear,
every pair is made with their signature modal fabric model.
Moodle proven to be twice as soft as cotton.
They don't just feel better than regular Andris. They make you feel invincible.
Jesus, they get bigger every time. Um,
it's guaranteed guaranteed to be the most comfortable underwear you've ever worn
or your first parents don't stop. So don't start your new year in old underwear.
Make a change and head to [inaudible] dot com slash pro right now and get 20%
off your first order order.
Plus shipping is always free for all orders in the U S and Canada.
So for 20% off for your first, yeah,
order of the world's most comfortable underwear. Head to me,
undies.com/ [inaudible] right now. All right,
here's the next two. I'm literally cooking a fucking egg right now.
Clip Debbie clubbed. Debbie a tear got stumped. Evil Doiche Club, Debbie,
we've all been there.
You come home after a long exhausting day at work and all you want to do is sip
a glass of wine and relax, but unless you've planned ahead,
you probably don't even have a bottle in your house.
You already spent enough time wandering around the grocery store.
Don't get lost in the wine aisle.
You just end up picking out a bottle based on the label.
You don't really get it. You get home and it sucks, right? You don't need that.
Please include all of the following points during your read. I'm going to,
if you write it, I'll read it. Well with club Debbie and terror,
my daddy owns the ranch. You never have to worry about being wind free again.
Club Debbie. I know Donald Rumsfeld, he actually ran.
The thing is a revolutionary new wine club that sends wine directly to your
door, saving you all of those trips to the grocery store.
Not only does club Debbie, I like to meet my Daddy. He got me a horse.
He when I was a kid, send you wine. They send you what you'll love.
Drinking club. Debbie, I'm running. Not a shit to say about this guy. Easy.
Six questions. Quick Quiz. Easy six questions.
Let me just get through this shit. I'm fucking late here. Six question.
Quiz figures out your palate.
So every bottle of wine you receive is personally tailored to your taste.
A this, it's leading the great to glass revolution.
They work directly with the vignettes to cut out the middleman,
which saves you money club, Debby. Huh? Reelect Mike. Rick,
how much do you vote for Jeb?
Could you help for Jib even offers no risk guarantees that you'll love. Well.
They'll send you a and right now club Debbie is offering my listeners 50% off
your first order when you go to club debby.com/bird don't ever come home with a
wine that tastes like shit again.
Just go to club Debby and.com/bird and get 50% off your first order.
Yeah.
All right. Legal Zoom off. Fuck fucking eggs again and be fucking over medium.
What am I Paul Versey? What am I fucking Paul Versey hang on.
He flipping them. Now this is the thing, man. If you fucking break the Yo,
that is an omen. I
got a big meeting today and I broke the fucking yellow. Well,
it's like just going to be no season two wait a minute. Fuck Dad.
I went one foot too bright. Cleo. I went one foot fucking two.
That's a good deal. All right. Legal Zoom, everybody before another season,
you ain't get off the fucking heat before another year.
Pass is take the time to get your life organized with legal zoom.
Do you have a family? Do you own any assets or property?
If any of these answers are yes, you should have an estate plan.
Don't worry if that sounds complicated cause legal zoom can help legal zooms
estate plan bundles. They eliminate the guesswork. You don't have to figure out,
uh, on your own whether a will are living truck works.
Trust works best for you. Instead,
you work with an independent attorney available in most states.
They'll walk you through your options and recommend an estate plan that offers
the best solution to fit your needs. Since legal zoom, it's not a law firm.
You can count on efficiency and value.
Everything is on your schedule and your terms. Plus,
you know what your estate plan bundled costs upfront instead of worrying about
hourly rates.
That's how legal zoom has become the leader in helping small business owners and
families with their legal needs. You get legal help and walk away feeling great.
Get your life organized with an estate plan. bundles@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter bar in the referral box at checkout that code. That's Code
burr@legalzoom.com. All right.
And lastly, but not leastly are old friends.
stamps.com one great resolution you can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every dollar for your small business.
I know an easy way to do that with
damn sorry.
Uh,
think about how much time you you've wasted at the post office driving there.
Finding parking, not getting laid.
stamps.com is a better way to get postage.
Just use what you already have your computer and printer to get official US
postage for any letter or package.
Then the mailman picks it up with stamps.com everything you would do at the post
office you can do right from your desk at a fraction of the cost and one of
those expensive postage meters. I use stamps.com to send out all my posters.
Anything fucking sell up to my shows. I use them.
I'm a moron if I can figure it out. So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last name, Burke for this special offer,
four week trial plus a lot,
$110 bonus offer that includes postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait. Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in [inaudible],
B U R r. Now back to some throwback podcast. She
[inaudible],
I don't know if they up the cock blocks all been defined,
like the different kinds of cock blocks.
I don't know if there's this names thrown, but I got a new,
I got a new cock block for you. Uh, this will,
this cock block is very special in a very obvious one.
And I think like this happens all the time,
but for some reason I've never heard anybody name it. So I'm, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna kick off the creative process. I call this guy the announcer.
That's the, uh, that's, that's the name of this cock block.
This is what happened to me. I was,
I did a Gig in Jersey and at the end of the night,
these two girls who waited to be at the back of the line came up and they said,
hey, you want to go out and get banana pancakes? You know,
making a reference to my joke saying if I wanted to go out and hang out with
both of them. Right. And the second day said it, I was like,
Holy Shit, here's a fucking, here's something I never had.
Here's a two on one and I can't fucking do it cause I'm with Nia. Who's kidding?
No. Cool. Not because I'm with Nias because everybody's got a cell phone,
fucking camera. And I get caught.
Honesty.
Um, no, I couldn't deal with the guilt. Um, but I gotta I'll be honest with you,
and I would say this, if Nia was here,
if two fucking tens came up to me and said, let's do this. I, I, you know,
yeah, fuck it. Let's do it. I never did it. You know, fuck it.
So anyways, so they said, hey, you want to get a,
you want to go on and get bananas and pancakes or something like that.
And then this fucking guy like 10 feet or way just goes like,
oh, what's going on over here?
You know those guys, like if a girl just comes up to you, just like, you know,
you know I've always loved guys in green shirts and you're thinking raise your
thinking like, holy fuck, this is going to happen.
There's some other guy like five minutes.
Hey, now why?
And just makes the whole fire the whole fucking room. Look over at you.
The fucking announcer.
Fucking cock block mother fucker. You know who would do that?
If I was standing there and I heard two girls say to a guy, I'd be like,
God damn, it's going down right side of my mouth at blocky mother fucker.
I wouldn't,
oh
yeah,
she wants the funnier mouth. Raleigh, other one watches. I mean,
why would you do that?
The fucking announcer. And if you have a friend like that, all right.
Yeah.
The only way you can still hang out with them is if he goes out.
If you guys are going out trying to meet women,
he has to wear one of those old ABC bright yellow Monday night football sport
coats.
Okay.
And if the girls, why is he wearing that? You'll see. You'll see.
And that'll be the, that would be the funniest fucking thing ever.
Like if somehow if he couldn't figure out the joke and he just thought the coat
look good and just the whole night you just saw him. Anytime you heard a in the,
you know, 10 feet away.
Yeah. What's this all about?
He does look over and you'd see this guy dressed like Howard Cosell.
You'd be like, oh, that's the announcer. He's the, he's the,
he's the guy he can cock block from. Like, he's almost like a sniper.
If he wasn't so fucking loud, he's at the same distance as a fucking marksman.
But uh, he kills it with, uh, with loudness. Oh my God.
Did that guy fucking annoy me? Hey Mia, come here. Come here.
She just came and shaking her head.
What I am beyond the come on over here.
I was just telling him that story with that Guy Cock blocked me with those two
chicks out in a Jersey where they would just go cock blocked you.
I told you this story.
No but you making it seem like you were going to do something and mean. No,
no I wasn't going to do something.
This is the thing but I just admitted general cock blocking. Yeah,
but this is what I did admit. If they were both tens I would've, I would've,
I would've done it.
I never had a fucker two on one and you know some that would you be that mad if
they were both smoking hot and the cell phone video got out.
The video is even need to get out when you got the announced today.
The guy he just literally goes like yeah,
we'd like to get it in pancakes as dod. He said something like wow,
what's good on over there?
Nothing. You're a jack. Why am I a jerk? So pajamas. Huh?
You are talking about cock blocking and two one one.
So what kind of podcast is turning into, you know,
what turned into a very honest podcast. I was very honest. I said, this is good.
This is the thing I said I couldn't, uh,
I couldn't deal with the guilt unless if they, if,
unless they were both tens, if they're both fucking tens, give me a break.
Let me tell you something. If you hooked up with Brad Pitt,
there's only so mad I could get. It's fucking Brad Pitt. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Well you know what that would, that if I just,
if I just said some generic good looking guy.
If I just said some generic good looking guy and you, and you just said that,
that would have scared me.
But the way you just acted like you had Brad Pitt's phone number,
that doesn't scare me. Oh really? Okay.
It's going down like the regular guy version of Brad pen.
Is that okay?
Like he's just as good if you want to go live out on the street and get the fuck
out of this house. Absolutely.
But you're allowed to have some sort of crazy two one one. Yes.
That's bull said. No it isn't. If he just, you know,
cause you're thinking on it on like, like a, a very basic level.
But if you really, if you really think about it, just think about it.
It makes sense. Bill.
You're not going to try to mind fuck me into thinking that it's okay for you to
have some sort of two on one and I can't, that's not, no,
it's not going down like that. Yeah, but God, women are beautiful.
We lust after you a totally makes sense. You guys find like Dick's are weird,
they're gross. It's all hanging out there. It's disgusting. You don't want that.
You know nothing about you. You don't want that,
which has been proven time and time and again,
and your stand up and on your podcast. But that's a, that's another discussion.
You know what you,
you just set yourself up like you're gonna make some huge point and then you
just tapped out. You know nothing about women but didn't.
But that's just another discussion and I just don't want even to get into that.
So now what, you just gave me the face. What are you doing today? Lazy. Huh?
Nini? Kubrick on my short film over the weekend. Screw you.
I'm working hard while you're in here in your pajamas talking about two on ones.
Yeah. Well I have to do an hour's worth of shit here. I'm coming up on it.
Fill it up. Let me go an hour and two minutes an hour.
Two minutes. Do you have your emails yet? Yeah, I did.
Listener emails. You did that already. Oh, cause you want to chime in?
I don't know. I already did it. I already did it. What about overrated?
Underrated. Didn't do it. They didn't have any this week. Oh, okay. Look at you.
I think you're a fan of this podcast. No, I'm not.
Listen, it didn't go down. All right.
But I'm telling you right now, Nia, if two tens come up to me,
it's going down. Okay. All right. Well I'll just be prepared for the retaliation
game set match. Really? You're going to deny me that?
Can I just buy you some stuff? Wow. Really? Yes.
Really not some sort of fucking basketball that can be placated with material
things to a point. Yeah, exactly. If I'm going to be fucking honest here,
come on, this gotta be something that I can buy. You know something.
This should be our Valentine's Day. All right. For the guy,
the Guy Valentine's Day,
this is what Valentine's Day should be every year is the guy gets a two on one
and then you get some nice stuff. Well why can't I have a two on one?
Cause you don't like that. What do you mean? What do you know?
Women don't like sex?
You don't find like when you guys fantasize,
you think about the guys in your life. You don't think about other things.
Um, come on Nia. Just one. Just give me one. You get one and I get one.
No you don't. You don't because you don't want one. What do you mean?
I don't want you just being childish. No I'm not. Yeah, you are.
[inaudible] you think you think you want to hook up with,
with Jake Gyllenhaal in a bread face, whatever the fuck his name is, Brad Pitt.
Brad Fred face pit. You just think you do. See,
you know what to think about me is like you have to hook up with somebody
famous. I'm actually just regular people. See I'm down to earth with this shit.
See that's what I'm saying. You like stuff you like shiny, shiny things.
This is deal. I get a two on one and you,
you get some some cracked up face old man in Vegas like Robert Redford.
Like I used to be good looking when Nixon was in office. No,
that's not how negotiating works.
Now you've got to come with something else here. No,
I think we should both get an equal opportunities thing going on.
This isn't an equal relationship. Why? Why is it not an equal relationship?
Because I wanted to,
I could pin you down to the ground right now and tickle you until you passed out
and there's not a fucking thing you can do about it. What did that,
that has nothing to do with anything. That's how the world works in here.
Why do you think America's on top? Because we're right or because we co because,
because we can blow you up more times. So it's your, your physical presence.
That's what makes it like an unequal relationship. Yeah.
Cause I can beat you down. Well, maybe you're physically stronger,
but I'm mentally stronger than you. Oh, snap.
I'm smarter than you. Yeah. So whatever physical power. Let me ask you this.
What is you have are trumped by my mental fucking Goliath Nus.
Suck on that red.
Why do you think you're smarter than, Oh, that was good though. Oh,
you got a good one in. Now you're storming off. I taught you. Well
[inaudible]
let's get to the complaints this week. Everybody asked,
some lady just absolutely lost her mind.
Hates my guts now and won't listen to this podcast anymore and I'd apologize to
her, but she said she's not listening anymore.
There's no way that she's listening.
Despite that she wrote like a five page email that I'm now going to read. Um,
she has a huge problem with me. Everybody. So settle it. Want me to wait?
You want to go down to the break room? Go get yourself a little coffee cake.
I'll, I can wait. I'm on vacation. I got nothing better to do. Go ahead.
I'll wait.
Fucking dog's been farting all day today. I don't know what his deal is.
And it keeps looking at me like, dude, you got to help me out.
And I keep going and take it outside.
And then it just sniffs the grass and then I bring it back in and starts farting
again. And it keeps looking at me like, dude,
I'm really trying not to shit on your rug. Like, I mean,
that's how I'm reading her face. I think that's what she's saying.
I have no idea. So anyways, uh, so anyways, there we go.
Um, subject. Your podcast is hate speech. Oh, geesh. Bill,
you probably won't read this or if you do,
you will just dismiss me as a stupid contour, but no matter,
see it right there. She's already draped herself in the arm.
Brave and I'm going to plow a head flag. Um,
your podcast as of late has morphed into hate speech.
He used to be funny and I could brush off your hateful comments with the cringe
and a shrug. Now wait a minute if it will,
if they were hateful right along, why would you add? Okay. Let's just plow him.
But now you've gone too far for me to feature a segment on your podcast,
devoted to the deplorable behavior of women is intolerable.
For those of you new to my podcast, uh, I've been doing this segment,
which I think is hilarious and needs to be done just to get you caught up before
this lady gives me both barrels here. Cause believe me, she does. Um, you know,
there's a bunch of, there's a bunch of shows out there that, that,
that shine a light on men who beat their women, those pieces of Shit, right?
Trying to stop them from that behavior.
There's a bunch of shows out there that we'll talk about how, uh,
who were these guys, you know,
to say what a woman could do with their body.
They'll talk about the glass ceiling,
the old boys network and all that type of stuff and they shine a light on all of
that. Okay. Which they should,
because that is guys doing things that they should not be doing.
That is not fair to women. Okay. But my,
so my problem is not that they do that.
My problem is that they never shine a light on shit that,
that women do that is not fair to men. So recently,
um, if I can rate Mike Drake myself in some sort of brave flag,
I've been reading these stories about guys who are married,
their wife goes out, cheats on them, has unprotected sex,
has a kid with another fucking guy,
doesn't tell their husband and that by the time he figures it out,
he has to pay child support for a kid that is isn't even his and it's totally
legal.
And then I had the audacity to say that a woman who would do that to her husband
is a cont.
Evidently that's hateful speech towards all women according to this person.
All right, because she continues and Oh, does she ever continue
to feature a segment on your podcast devoted to the deplorable behavior of women
is intolerable.
How is that any different than someone spending 20 minutes a week on a different
podcast featuring the deplorable behavior behavior of black people?
Why do they always go to black people? That's always a,
that's just like calling me the n word.
This is no different than slavery though.
That's people in other groups always do that. Always do that. All right.
Give me a goddamn break. All right. That she, she goes,
women are, I mean, how is that different? I'm how was,
how was what I'm doing any different by by featuring a segment of women who are
doing something absolutely reprehensible demand.
How is that any different than a show that focuses on men doing anything
reprehensible to women when they show wife beaters? I don't look at that like,
oh my God, they're saying I'm doing it too.
I think you know something.
I really think you're being really selfish here and the fact that you could sit
here and listen to my podcast for this, long as I've gone off on fat people.
I mean, Jesus Christ want to talk about hate speech.
How much shit have I talked about Peyton Manning,
despite the fact I can't even throw a football. You know,
if he sent me an email,
I would understand and I bet it wouldn't even be as crazy as this. She says,
women are treated like second class citizens all over the world.
When did I ever say they weren't?
And even still in this country yet you have no problem inciting further hate and
discus towards your fellow human beings on this earth.
How am I inciting hate when when shows show wife beaters is that inciting hatred
towards men? If you look at those shows and that makes you hate all men,
then you're a moron.
So basically what you're saying is that I'm a moron and that all my listeners
are morons. That if I call a woman who cheats on her husband,
has a baby with another guy and makes her husband pay for that,
if I call her a cunt, that means I'm calling all women cunts, you know?
Is that what you're saying? Are you saying we're all that stupid? She said,
right now there are men and that is written in capital letters, men,
men in country still capital s t I l l discussing whether or not women should
have the right to contraception and abortion. Yeah, I understand that.
And those people freak me out.
Those people freak me up and I am a guy and I've never said that a woman
shouldn't have a right to that. So I don't know what you're talking about.
This has nothing to do.
I'm talking about these fucking whores that cheat on their husbands.
Ma'Am. You know what I love about all this?
How come you don't address what I talked about?
How come I can't hear what,
what do you think about a woman who would do something like that?
I saw a stat the other day that said 13% of kids in this country are not with
their biological father. Meaning that not just like,
you know, that, that their wife got like divorced and uh,
and then remarried.
They mean like there's a guy either knows or doesn't know.
Like the woman had a kid with somebody else while they were married,
like 13% of kids. I mean, that means 80% of women are on the up and up.
All right? God bless them. They're angels.
But that 13% needs to be taken to task. I mean, I, I mean,
how many guys have beaten women?
I would guess there'd probably be right around that same, you know,
maybe a little higher. I have no idea. Let's just, let's say it's 20 plus,
say 20% of guys beat their women,
should they not be called out and be called cowardly pieces of shit,
you know, and if you call them cowardly piece of Shit, what?
I have a right to sit there and look at that and be like, well that's,
now you're, you're inciting further hate and disgust toward all men.
You're being really selfish here, man, because I go off on everybody.
This podcast is over the top and it's crazy.
I call guys cunts on this podcast and you're being really selfish right now and
now you know,
you make this big long speech and then you're going to take your ball and go
home. I look at this, look at all she's bringing up here.
Women are still earn only 70 cents for every dollar a man earns.
I think you guys should make the same amount,
but I also don't think that that that number is accurate.
$77 77 cents for every dollar that a man or is,
because if you include divorce settlements, a,
you get to keep your 77 cents plus his 50% his 50 cents.
So then he's down to 50 and then you're up to a dollar 37
that's what I'm talking about right there. Go Fuck Yourself.
You're over-sensitive Jackass. Good Lord.
Go buy a bigger bra. I don't know what your fucking problem is.
I hope that bugs you too,
that I said that that was deliberately supposed to be offensive. All right,
so go fucking write a letter to a fucking cut hair.com cause I don't give a
shit. All right? In short,
we are still not equal to our male counterparts and we will forever be labeled
the weaker sex. While with that attitude, of course you will. You know,
I don't think you're the weaker sex. I think that that's all a myth.
I think that actually makes you stronger. You know,
because guys are fucking idiots and they think because they can do more pushups
than their woman, that they're actually, you know, that makes them smarter.
You know, I dunno. Ah, my fucking doorbell's ringing. Are you serious?
Hang on a second.
I got to go up here and then I gotta I gotta read the rest of this. Hold on.
Okay.
All right. So I'm back. Little winded, but I'm back. I'm back. So anyways,
Blahblahblahblahblah it just keeps going on and on and on and on. Um,
where the hell is it?
Yeah.
Where the hell was I?
A weaker sex and then she tries to break me down psychologically,
but my mom not hugging me. If that's the case,
then I'm sorry for you. I hate when people do that.
It's like you're not sorry for me. You hate me right now. Okay,
so stop acting like you're really sorry for me.
And you're showing some sort of empathy. You're not showing empathy,
you're being really selfish. Like I said, I go off on everything here.
I've never said that a woman shouldn't make the same amount and hours a guy.
I never should said that a guy should be able to hit a woman.
I've never said that.
What the thing I'm trying to shine a light too is that some of these divorce
settlements are absolutely fucking ridiculous and,
and that when a woman cheats on a guy and has,
has a kid with another person and then the poor sapele married or has to pay for
that, you don't think that's fucked up.
How would start just did a great story on it. Uh,
last week somebody sent me an email,
he did a story about a guy who was in that situation and he refused to play,
pay the child support and they said, we're going to send you to jail.
He's going to go to jail because his wife cheated on him, had unprotected sex.
Hey to hell with aids. Let's roll the dice with my husband's life. Right.
Has unprotected sex, has a kid.
He doesn't realize it figures it's his cause. It's his, his wife's pregnant.
Why wouldn't you think that it's somebody else's? He starts making the payments.
Next thing you know, he's such raising the kid figures out it's not his kid.
And as a natural reaction, I don't want to pay for that. And the like,
the law is just like, no, you have to pay for it. Let me ask you this, ma'am.
Do you have any empathy for that?
You seem to have all this empathy for women and women's issues and like somehow
I'm supposed to still respect you despite the fact that you could give a fuck if
there's injustice is done on the other side.
It doesn't make any sense and I want to see like,
okay,
this is like focusing on this issue. This is an issue.
For some reason that is just not talked about whatsoever.
It's just sort of accepted.
Yeah,
and I think it's an absolute, I think it's absolutely deplorable.
I think it's deplorable. So I, I have the right to talk about it.
You know what I mean?
And if you want to get offended and you want to be selfish and just be like,
well that isn't fair.
What if I had a whole segment every week and all I did was talk about wife
beaters. You know what? You'd probably send me an email.
I just want you to tell you I love your podcast even more. It is just, it's,
you are just,
you are a hero to hear a man out there just,
just letting these, these, these cowardly pieces of shit know that it's,
you be fucking over the motorbike. Okay.
But now all of a sudden I'm talking about women who are doing shit that you're
not even doing.
Yeah.
At what point in any of these stupid fucking rants that I [inaudible] done.
Have I ever said that all women are doing this? I never have. I never said that.
All women cheat on their husbands and an advocate out of wedlock. I didn't.
All right. Do I make generalizations? A fucking Lilly, it's a comedy.
I paint with a broad brush. I'm fucking around. Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ up being so God damn selfish. Okay.
And if you don't want to listen to my podcast,
don't listen to my podcast anymore. And uh, other than that, you know,
I mean go fuck yourself. I, I don't, I don't,
I don't know this, what she's doing is, is, is a,
is a pet peeve that I have. Um,
like that happens to me. Like,
sometimes when I do shows and at the end of my shows,
some will come up to me and just be like, look, you know,
I have a good sense of humor, but, but subject, whatever,
my fucking phone, they'll just be like, you know what? That's never funny.
That is never, oh the lovely Nia. Everybody, hang on one second.
Hang on one second. Hello.
Hey, I'm taping my podcast right now. Is this urgent?
Are you on the side of the road? We got AAA
already.
No, no. I, I, the dog was farting and I thought I'd had to shit in the house.
So I took it outside and then it just sniffed around and peed. Yeah,
it was a pain in the ass. So I'm going to get back to the podcast. All right.
All right. I'll tell you in like a half. Alright, bye. Um,
anyways. Oh, then she goes on to say that the terms I use will then,
cause you know, people to use the, you know, it's,
I fuck around and use these terms.
She then thinks that people are gonna use them seriously. You know what I mean?
And I'm sure a few will, but that's not on me. Somebody who does that,
it's because you're a moron and like it's not my responsibility to fucking
babysit anybody once they're an adult.
If you don't know not to call women these terms. Okay.
Although I will tell you this, if, uh,
you know, there is a time to call a woman a cunt, okay?
And then that's when you find out that your son is not your son and you still
have to pay for it. There's a reason that that word does, it does exist.
All right. All right, this sweetheart. So I hope you come back to the podcast.
I hope that you actually listen and will respond.
And I don't want to hear another fucking word out of you unless you tell me what
you think about those kinds of fucking women who do that. Okay.
And stop bringing up slavery and all this other shit and try to drag all this
other crap into it. All right? You stay in your own goddamn lane, sweetheart.
All right?
Yeah.
Good Lord.
Okay.
So to compare yourself not being able to vote to being enslaved.
Really.
Okay.
That's another one that gets, that's a whole nother fucking topic.
Every fucking person out there just tries to fucking jump on that,
you know?
That's our Edward Gow. Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm Eddie.
I can't believe you just did that. Why did you flick that big right in my face?
You burned off two eyebrow hairs. That's my trend.
[inaudible].